foreign
your words
it opened up this door that helped me
that supported me in
a deeper understanding
that everything that I was pursuing
was um
fruitless to a great extent
and so
I wanted to start with
that first statement here fear exists
only in the presence
of consequences
I don't know if I heard you say that or
if I saw you write it but that was
apparent to me that I was fearing a lot
of things because I was ultimately
afraid
of the consequence
and often that consequence was I was
terrified of what other people
might think of me
can you help me better understand
where that comes from
where what comes from
that that fear of
caring so profoundly and deeply
about what other people might think well
let's look it's it's the
it's the world that a human being builds
without knowing that he builds it
because it's the only world he knows
and it's it he he creates he lives in
the larger world and then he creates
smaller worlds out of the larger world
and the smaller worlds are in the form
of relationship in the form of image in
the form of trying to please others and
trying to
um
impress others and gain favor and all of
these things and
um it it it's critical for me to say at
this juncture that none of those things
are wrong none of those things are good
it's
they are just a
a side effect and a consequence of being
worldly
um and any attempt actually to fix those
things just leaves you more and further
and further into worldliness and the
further and further you get into
worldliness the further and further you
drift out to sea so it doesn't really
matter what the detail is
um a worldly life is all suffering
uh it's all misery it you can paint it
however you like you can put on a smile
and say you're happy with your
circumstances or you have a lot to be
thankful for and have a gratitude
journal and all this nonsense if you
wish
um but it's it's just trying to find a
pocket of air within a uh a state of
drowning and and once again there's
nothing wrong with that but whatever
issue you choose is simply a detailed
form of suffering
um because one has become worldly and
one has therefore uh has respect and for
the world and values the world and
therefore he values all the things that
are said within it by its uh
spiritualists and it's self-helpists and
its minions and its experts and he
imbibes that and he reads books and he
listens to media and he hears interviews
and he uh listens to talks and he
imbibes all of that information and he
goes off upon the Journey of what are
fundamentally lies and they're not
necessarily intentional lies in fact I
don't believe that most people are out
to hurt people I don't believe that at
all I believe that most people are
trying to help people most so-called
experts are trying to do good for their
fellow man I firmly believe that
um but the effect remains that it still
all lies and and when I say it's lies I
mean that's no one should ever believe
me on that that's something that they
have to they can examine for themselves
because if they believe me and say well
you're saying it's a lie so then give me
the truth then then it's going to be
everything being dependent upon what I
say and that has no relevance everything
everything comes down to realizations
for oneself
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free